the threat that this is somehow coming
for all of these women or no one will be
able to get abortions or any of these
things regardless of what you feel about
abortion it's just simply not true but
what they have exposed themselves to be
are petulant children who are not
getting their way and that's what we
have to treat them if you what would you
do if a child was just screaming and
stamping their feet and everything else
is the best thing to just give them what
they want or is it to ignore them or
teach them some sort of a lesson i think
i'm not a parent yet
but i think it's the latter
here is a lefty progressive democrat
sort of an ancillary squad member
pramala jayapal on cnn saying that godis
doesn't even have the right to make
decisions about these sorts of things
i can tell you this is a stunning
stunning rebuke of precedent
and of the fundamental freedom that
women have to make choices about our own
bodies and our own futures and our own
economic security and the thing is
victor
that these justices are acting like
this is somehow something that they have
the right to change they do not have the
right to change this which has been
settled law for two generations now of
people who have grown up who have gone
through their 20s in the firm belief
that they can make these decisions about
their own bodies all right so just to be
clear i mean she's just wrong like
that's just a lie of course the supreme
court is allowed to look at prior
decisions and make current decisions
right that's exactly what they do they
reverse course on some things every now
and again they usually expand rights to
people that's generally what the court
has done they reverse wrong decisions in
this case what alito is writing about
and we'll see what the other briefs are
but what alito is saying is there is no
basis in the constitution that makes
abortion a federal right so all we're
doing is letting it go back to the
states because we have a federal system
and states are supposed to do most of
the stuff but that's what's happening on
cnn a progressive lefty gets on there
and just lies so again if you're just
watching stuff if you're just watching
stuff happen if you're the average
person oh my god elizabeth warren is
screaming about stuff she must be right
she's screaming and she's wearing a pink
dress and everyone around her is so
upset they must kind of be right because
they're screaming and then a few minutes
later you get a progressive to go on
there and completely lie to you
about what the supreme court actually
does and how they analyze the law and
what
over time they're allowed to look at and
decide what decisions are right and what
decisions are wrong this is this is how
the whole freaking thing works but if
you think that msnbc
can't stoop lower than freaking out
because a
baby might become a child or because an
embryo might become a child a fetus
might become a child here's a genuine
crazy person i mean i i know i joke
about a lot of the crazy people and they
are crazy people this guy's name is
ellie mistahl and uh well
take a look
alito's fundamental legal reasoning is
that abortion is not a fundamental right
because it doesn't go back to the
founding because the founding fathers
didn't recognize abortion as a
fundamental right and he's right about
that the founding fathers didn't
recognize abortion as a fundamental
right because the founding fathers were
racist misogynist jerk faces who didn't
believe that women had any rights at all
so of course they didn't believe that
women's had rights to their own bodies
the founding fathers didn't believe that
marital rape was a thing
couldn't be a thing according to the
founding fathers according to sam alito
so that's the history that sam alito is
is is accessing
first off if you're getting political
analysis from a guy with a head of hair
like that you really should think about
what you're doing he looks like he's
half albert einstein half fat albert
okay that's number one
number two uh the founding fathers were
jerk faces that's a good one that's the
level of analysis that's going on over
there um it's just complete ridiculous
these people are are insane
you